industry accelerators for ibm cloud pack
for data as a service a visual studio
code extension and the ga of ibm cloud
linux one for vpc all on this episode of
ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back to bring you the latest and
greatest news and announcements from ibm
cloud
if you and your organization are looking
for a great way to get started with ai
quickly i've got something for you
we're going to begin this week with a
look at the all new industry
accelerators for ibm cloud pack for data
as a service
these industry accelerators are
downloadable and customizable sample
applications built for actual use cases
to help you learn about specific
challenges
they provide a pre-built package of
assets that demonstrates how to address
common business issues allowing you to
go from demonstration to implementation
in hours rather than weeks or even
months
a typical accelerator workflow allows
you to clean and prepare data run
machine learning algorithms and score
the resulting model
in short this is the perfect way to
close the data science skills gap and
quickly get started with ai that is
tailored to your business needs
we've got industry accelerators
available around highly requested
business use cases in the financial
markets energy and utilities and
insurance industries
to get started with any of these
projects visit the ibm cloud pack for
data as a service gallery that you can
find through the link i've got in the
description of this video
up next i want to talk about the beta
release of a visual studio code
extension for ibm cloud schematics
this extension can be installed on an
existing visual studio code installation
with it you can develop test and deploy
your terraform templates from within the
vs code without the need to switch
between github and the ibm cloud console
ui or cli
so what does this mean
simply put it eases the iteration in
developing terraform templates with ibm
cloud schematics
this extension also provides three
custom tasks for vs code you can use the
build task to author and validate your
terraform templates
got the deploy task to deploy the
terraform template to schematics and you
can use the clone task to clone the
terraform template from either an
existing schematics workspace or new git
repository
to try out the visual studio code
extension for ibm cloud schematics check
out the link i've got below
to wrap things up for this episode i'm
excited to announce the general
availability of ibm cloud linux 1 for
vpc
linux 1 for vpc are virtual servers
based on the linux 1 processor
architecture that bring the advantages
of the platform together with the
advantages of virtual private cloud
this means that linux one is available
as a choice in the public cloud for the
first time and it provides unique
options if you're looking to develop in
the public cloud with the backing of an
enterprise-grade linux server
besides the virtual private cloud these
virtual servers come with a litany of
other benefits including simplified
logging and monitoring backup and
restore file share snapshot and much
more to get started with ibm cloud linux
one for vpc hit the link i've got below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description in
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in the cloud
now
you